- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance est ouverte.
Madame la Première ministre,
mesdames et messieurs les membres
du gouvernement, mesdames et
messieurs les députés, mes chers
collègues, avant d'appeler l'ordre
du jour, je voudrais saluer le
secrétaire général de l'Assemblée
nationale et de la présidence, qui
est assis derrière moi.
Applaudissements
...
Il participe aujourd'hui à sa
dernière séance de questions au
gouvernement.
C'est une vie au service de
l'Assemblée nationale.
Il y est entré en 1981.
Il en a gravi tous les échelons,
jusqu'à atteindre le plus élevé
d'entre eux en 2016.
Il a servi notre institution avec
l'exigence et le professionnalisme
qui font honneur à la fonction
publique parlementaire.
Je tiens à l'assurer en votre nom
à tous de la reconnaissance
sincère de l'Assemblée nationale.
Merci.
...
Merci beaucoup, Michel.
Je vous remercie.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par monsieur Jordan Guitton.
- Jordan Guitton: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie et des
Finances.
Alors qu'un Français sur trois ne
partira pas en vacances cet été,
alors que la période estivale est
déjà impactée par une inflation
globale, alors que certaines
urgences seront fermées comme dans
mon département, alors que la
France connaît la plus haute
augmentation de faillites
d'entreprises de son histoire,
alors qu'en février les factures
d'électricité ont déjà augmenté de
15%, nous apprenons aujourd'hui
une nouvelle hausse de 10% du prix
de l'électricité.
Concrètement, la hausse réelle des
prix de l'électricité est de 31%
sur les six derniers mois.
Où est votre parole lorsque vous
annonciez qu'il n'y aurait pas de
rattrapage sur les prix de
l'électricité en 2023?
Par votre mensonge, vous avez
alimenté la défiance de nos
compatriotes envers la parole
publique.
Quand allez-vous reprendre le
contrôle sur les prix de
l'électricité et enfin appliquer
les mesures de bon sens portées
par Marine Le Pen, en revenant aux
tarifs réglementés, en
désindexant le prix de
l'électricité sur celui du gaz, en
abaissant le taux de TVA de 20 à
5,5 sur toutes les énergies, en
soutenant une politique ambitieuse
sur le nucléaire, en sortant des
règles du marché européen de
l'électricité?
Vos promesses de réformes ont
lamentablement échoué devant le
refus allemand.
Avec ces mesures, nous serions
attractifs pour l'économie et pour
le pouvoir d'achat des Français.
Avec vous, c'est la double peine
pour les Français: on paye
toujours plus de taxes et une
électricité toujours plus chère.
Ma question est simple: allez-vous
agir ou allez-vous partir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Agnès Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Monsieur
le député Jordan Guitton, même si
cela vous déplaît de le
reconnaître, la France est le pays
qui a le plus protégé ses
concitoyens face à l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie ces deux
dernières années.
C'est ce gouvernement et cette
majorité qui ont agi fortement dès
le début de la crise énergétique
pour protéger les Français, les
collectivités locales et les
entreprises face aux hausses des
prix de l'électricité:
bouclier tarifaire, amortisseur
électricité, filet de sécurité,
chèque énergie, autant de
dispositifs mis en place en un
temps record ces deux dernières
années.
Cet effort, c'est 40 milliards
d'euros rien que pour le bouclier
électricité sur la période
2022-2023.
C'est un choix assumé pour que les
Français bénéficient des prix
d'électricité parmi les plus bas
d'Europe.
La majorité présidentielle peut
être fière d'avoir mis tout ce qui
était en son pouvoir pour protéger
les Français.
Comme à son habitude, le
Rassemblement National parle
beaucoup.
Nous avons pris nos
responsabilités.
Si nous n'avions pas agi, les
factures des Français auraient
doublé en février.
Selon la commission de régulation
de l'énergie, les tarifs de
l'électricité auraient été
augmentés de près de 75%.
Le gouvernement n'a pas suivi ce
calcul et a opté pour une hausse
limitée de 10%.
Aussi, nous serons extrêmement
vigilants, avec le ministre de
l'Economie et des Finances: le
maintien du bouclier tarifaire
permettra de prendre en charge
plus du tiers de la facture des
Français.
C'est massif.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Jordan Guitton?
- Jordan Guitton: Par votre
réponse, vous avez trahi les
entreprises et les artisans par
vos choix économiques.
Vous avez trahi nos fleurons par
électoralisme.
Vous avez trahi les Français par
la parole.
Un jour ou l'autre, ils vous
balayeront par les urnes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Loïc Kervran.
- Loïc Kervran: Merci.
Si vous le permettez, je
souhaiterais commencer cette
intervention en rendant hommage à
une jeune sapeur-pompier de ma
circonscription décédée en
intervention samedi.
Applaudissements
...
Merci pour elle.
Je veux redire à sa famille, ses
proches et ses camarades à quel
point la nation est triste, mais
aussi fière de son engagement et
des valeurs qu'elle portait.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le garde des Sceaux.
Il y a plus d'une semaine, les
Françaises et les Français ont été
les témoins de scènes d'une
violence inouïe: 12.000 voitures
brûlées, 105 incendies et
dégradations de mairies, 168
attaques d'école, 17 atteintes aux
élus.
La lecture de ces chiffres
témoigne de la gravité des
exactions commises.
Alors que nous allons discuter
cette semaine dans ces murs d'une
loi mettant les moyens pour
réparer les conséquences de ces
violences, j'aimerais que vous
nous rassuriez sur le fait que ces
actes ne resteront pas impunis.
Je vous parle depuis les
territoires ruraux comme le mien,
mais aussi depuis les zones
touchées où beaucoup ont vu avec
effarement ce déchaînement.
La réponse des forces de sécurité
sur l'instant a été à la hauteur,
et je remercie encore nos forces
de l'ordre.
Il ne doit pas subsister de doute
sur la réponse pénale.
Notre pays a besoin que la loi
s'applique dans sa fermeté à tous.
Je sais votre engagement.
La circulaire adressée aux
procureurs il y a quelques jours
appelait à une réponse ferme,
systématique et rapide.
Vous avez aussi fait entrer en
vigueur le code de la justice
pénale des mineurs, qui réforme
totalement le traitement
judiciaire des affaires impliquant
des mineurs délinquants ou
criminels.
Pouvez-vous nous dire en quoi
cette nouvelle procédure va
permettre de répondre efficacement
aux profils de ces émeutiers
parfois très jeunes?
Sur les réquisitions et les peines
prononcées, où en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui?
Pourriez-vous détailler la réponse
pénale que les tribunaux ont
apportée aux récentes émeutes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Monsieur le
député Loïc Kervran, permettez-moi
d'abord de m'associer au vibrant
hommage que vous avez rendu à la
jeune Manon, sapeur-pompier
volontaire de votre département.
Son engagement et celui de tous
ceux qui protègent la République
nous oblige tous.
Dans ma circulaire du 30 juin 2023
sur les violences urbaines et dans
la dépêche relative aux festivités
du 14 juillet, j'ai demandé et je
demande encore ici devant la
représentation nationale
que les procureurs de notre pays,
totalement mobilisés et auxquels
je veux ici solennellement rendre
hommage, apportent une réponse
pénale ferme, rapide,
systématique.
C'est le triptyque qui définit la
politique pénale de fermeté sans
aucune démagogie.
J'ai aussi rappelé avec force que
les personnes qui appellent à la
violence et à la haine via les
réseaux sociaux ne sauraient se
retrancher derrière l'anonymat.
Il n'y a pas de zone de non-droit.
De nombreuses poursuites ont été
engagées.
Plus d'une dizaine de premières
condamnations sont déjà tombées.
Après plus de 15 jours, le bilan
de cette circulaire est à la
hauteur.
Les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes.
Entre le 27 juin et le 13 juillet,
1278 jugements ont été prononcés,
avec 95% de condamnations, et
souvent avec mandat de dépôt.
608 mineurs ont été déférés.
La justice a répondu présent pour
faire revenir l'ordre républicain
aux côtés des policiers et des
gendarmes, mais après 30 ans
d'abandon, elle a besoin que vous
répondiez présent.
Tous les républicains sur ces
bancs, de gauche à droite...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Jean-Claude Raux.
- Jean-Claude Raux: Merci.
Nous sommes le 18 juillet.
La canicule accable une partie de
l'Europe, avec une vague de
chaleur qui fait exploser le
thermomètre au-delà des 40 degrés.
Malgré le deuxième mois de juin le
plus chaud dans notre pays, le
déni climatique du gouvernement ne
rougit pas.
Le ministre de l'Agriculture
considère que ces températures
n'ont rien d'extrême et sont
plutôt normales pour un été.
Non, monsieur le ministre, rien
n'est normal dans ce que nous
vivons.
Notre maison brûle, et 21 ans
après la formule célèbre du
président Chirac, nous regardons
toujours ailleurs.
En France, il est évident que vous
n'avez toujours pas pris la mesure
du combat à livrer.
Nous sommes le 18 juillet,
toujours pas de conseil de
planification écologique, à
nouveau reporté.
Le réchauffement climatique, lui,
ne recule pas.
Ce n'est pas la priorité du
président Macron.
Il élève au rang d'officier de la
Légion d'honneur le président de
TotalEnergies, dont les projets
écocides se poursuivent au même
rythme que ses profits indécents.
Hier, la Cour des comptes a publié
un rapport sévère sur l'absence de
planification opérationnelle pour
faire face à la dramatique
raréfaction de la ressource en
eau.
Pourtant, des plans, il y en a, et
certains pays ont déjà pris la
mesure de l'ampleur des décisions
à prendre.
Le pays de Galles annule ses
projets routiers, car impossible
d'atteindre le 0 carbone à moins
d'arrêter de faire la même chose
encore et encore.
Ici, cette semaine, on essaye de
nous vendre la fable de
l'industrie verte qui prétend
résoudre par magie nos problèmes
de décarbonation.
Nous n'attendons pas de la part de
votre gouvernement des lendemains
qui chantent, mais pour éviter des
lendemains qui brûlent et qui
épuisent les ressources, quand
allez-vous enfin prendre vos
responsabilités et agir à la
hauteur de l'immense défi qui nous
fait face?
La pensée magique n'existe pas.
Quand allez-vous enfin sortir du
déni?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Monsieur le député Jean-Claude
Raux, quand allez-vous enfin
sortir des discours et des mots
tout faits?
Quand allez-vous regarder, y
compris le dernier rapport du Haut
Conseil pour le climat et les
propos de la présidente, qui
rappellent qu'il y a 18 pays sur
la planète qui, depuis plus de 10
ans, baissent tous les ans leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre?
Quand allez-vous regarder les
chiffres qui montrent que la
baisse pour l'année passée a été
conséquente en termes d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre?
Oui, nous devons accélérer.
Nous devons doubler le rythme de
notre baisse.
La vérité, c'est que l'on doit
agir sur tous les fronts, sur
l'adaptation, c'est qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un réchauffement
climatique qui est déjà
irréversible.
Il faut agir aussi sur
l'atténuation, à la fois en France
mais aussi en mobilisant la
diplomatie pour avoir d'autres
acteurs qui se mobilisent à nos
côtés.
Nous devons agir avec la
planification écologique.
Si les écologistes arrêtaient de
penser que l'avenir de leur
planète est leur fonds de
commerce, on aurait plus de chances
de s'en sortir.
Alors, je vous invite à sortir des
postures.
Je vous invite à regarder en face
la réalité.
Je vous invite à nous soutenir
quand ça va dans le bon sens.
Je vous invite à saluer les 7
milliards d'euros annoncés par la
Première ministre.
Je vous invite à saluer les
efforts de formation qui ont été
lancés.
Je vous invite à soutenir le plan
d'adaptation.
eau.
Au motif que ce n'est pas vous qui
le présentez, vous faites comme si
ça n'était rien.
Les Français ne sont pas dupes.
Sinon, vous seriez dans une autre
situation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Gabriel Amard.
- Gabriel Amard: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
l'Europe est frappée par une
chaleur intense qui s'étend
désormais sur toute la France et
le bassin méditerranéen.
Dans ce contexte compliqué pour
nos concitoyens, les propos de
votre ministre de l'Agriculture
samedi sur France Inter ne sont
pas acceptables.
Non, nous ne connaissons pas des
températures normales pour un été.
68% des nappes phréatiques sont à
des niveaux sous les normales de
saison et ne sont pas rechargées
depuis l'été dernier.
Le mois de juin a été le mois le
plus chaud après celui de 2003.
Les Français souffrent au travail
et chez eux, pendant que les
ultra-riches que vous récompensez
par des Légions d'honneur comme le
PDG de TotalEnergies poursuivent
avec gourmandise depuis des salons
climatisés leur sport préféré:
détruire la planète.
Qu'ont-ils fait pour mériter les
honneurs de la nation?
Sûrement pas d'avoir agi pour que
les 330.000 sans-abris supportent
la vague de chaleur.
Qu'en est-il pour nos concitoyens
de Mayotte, qui doivent faire face
depuis hier à des coupures d'eau?
Je vous adressais ce matin une
lettre pour vous demander de
déclencher un débat en hémicycle
pour un plan d'urgence eau pour
Mayotte.
Ma question: au lieu de décorer le
roi du pétrole, quand est-ce que
vous agirez concrètement au
service de la planète?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Monsieur le
député Gabriel Amard, je suis
heureux de vous entendre parler du
climat, parce que les seules
températures qui vous
intéressaient jusqu'à maintenant,
c'était celles des émeutes
urbaines.
Depuis des semaines, quand ce
gouvernement a présenté le 20 juin
dernier son plan de gestion des
vagues de chaleur, où étiez-vous?
Où étiez-vous au début du mois de
juillet quand on parlait de l'eau?
Vous souffliez sur les braises des
émeutes dans les banlieues et les
seules températures qui vous
intéressent, c'était celles-là.
Venir ici, prendre un micro et
faire en sorte de créer une
polémique parce que votre seul
objet, ce n'est pas de parler des
vagues de chaleur mais de parler
du président de Total...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame
Mathilde Panot!
Madame la présidente!
- Christophe Béchu: Les
vociférations de madame Panot n'y
changeront rien!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît, mes chers collègues,
un peu de calme.
ce n'est pas ça.
- Christophe Béchu: Que vous
veniez ici pour tenter de faire
diversion, ça ne trompe personne.
Les Français ne sont pas dupes.
Vous voulez débattre du fond,
faisons-le!
La planification écologique, c'est
nous.
Les budgets, c'est nous.
L'adaptation, c'est nous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
- Christophe Béchu: Il vous reste
l'outrance et les fake news.
Vous confondez l'écologie
politique avec la sauvegarde de la
planète.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Un peu de
silence, s'il vous plaît.
Monsieur Gabriel Amard?
- Gabriel Amard: Vos provocations
n'y changeront rien, monsieur le
ministre.
Ca prouve que vous êtes en manque
d'inspiration.
Alors, je vous invite à
télécharger notre plan eau sur
notre site Internet.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole...
Un peu de silence, s'il vous
plaît.
La parole est à Philippe Latombe.
- Philippe Latombe: Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame la
présidente Mathilde Panot, s'il
vous plaît!
Vous n'avez pas la parole!
- Philippe Latombe: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères.
Dans une réaction commune sans
précédent, la quasi-totalité des
partis politiques et groupes
parlementaires des parlements
français et européens se sont tous
retrouvés pour contester la
nomination par la Commission
européenne à la direction générale
de la concurrence.
Ce n'est en aucun cas
une remise en cause de son parcours
universitaire,
mais de son activité de lobbyiste
pour Amazon,
Apple et Microsoft entre autres
et de son tropisme avéré en faveur
des grandes sociétés.
Nous n'avons pas là le profil
d'une future fonctionnaire au
service de l'Union Européenne,
bien plutôt d'un conflit d'intérêts
latent.
Cette nomination intervient dans
un contexte d'adaptation par le
Parlement de notre droit national
des règlements européens qui
prévoient de limiter la domination
économique des grandes
plates-formes et la diffusion en
ligne de contenus et de produits
illicites.
Parler d'un fâcheux hasard tient
de l'euphémisme.
Couvrons ce conflit d'intérêts que
nous ne saurions voir, semble dire
la Commission, qui propose que la
nouvelle chef économie se mette en
retrait de ses missions chaque
fois qu'un conflit d'intérêts
s'annoncera.
On peut ainsi s'interroger sur la
crédibilité d'un tel choix,
l'intérêt de placer à une telle
fonction une personne qui ne
pourra de toute façon que très
partiellement l'exercer.
Le groupe démocrate ne comprend pas
cette nomination.
L'Europe n'a-t-elle pas la
capacité à trouver en son sein
parmi 447 millions de personnes
une compétence digne de ce poste?
Nous souhaitons savoir comment
vous envisagez de convaincre la
Commission européenne de revenir
sur cette décision.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Monsieur le
député Philippe Latombe, je vous
prie d'abord de bien vouloir
excuser l'absence de la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères, qui rentre du Conseil
de sécurité des Nations Unies à
New York.
Sans se prononcer sur les qualités
professionnelles de cette
Américaine dont vous parlez, cette
nomination au poste d'économiste
en chef de la direction générale
de la concurrence à la Commission
européenne suscite de nombreuses
interrogations légitimes.
Par la voix de la ministre
Catherine Colonna, ce gouvernement
a rapidement réagi et nous l'avons
fait de manière publique, car ce
sujet est d'intérêt collectif.
C'est également votre cas, comme
le montre votre question.
Il faut aussi relever de
nombreuses voix qui se sont
élevées au Parlement européen,
notamment les présidents de groupe
qui ont écrit à la Commission
européenne dès la semaine
dernière.
En substance, cette nomination
fait peser un risque sérieux de
conflit d'intérêts, alors que la
régulation numérique fait figure
de priorité pour l'Union
Européenne.
Il est difficilement justifiable
de nommer quelqu'un dont les
activités professionnelles
antérieures consistaient à
promouvoir précisément les
intérêts des grandes entreprises
directement concernées.
Depuis, cette nomination soulève
une question politique.
Aucun pays ne confierait de telles
responsabilités à un ressortissant
étranger.
C'est une question évidente de
souveraineté européenne.
Nous attendons donc de la
Commission qu'elle réexamine cette
nomination.
Nous le lui avons dit très
précisément.
L'objectif n'est pas de s'immiscer
dans le pouvoir de nomination de
la Commission, qui lui appartient,
mais nous attendons de cette
dernière qu'elle fasse preuve de
tout le discernement et de toute
la rigueur nécessaires dans la
nomination à des postes aussi
stratégiques.
La ministre Catherine Colonna
abordera ce sujet lors du Conseil
des ministres des Affaires
étrangères ce jeudi, cette
semaine.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Meyer Habib.
- Meyer Habib: Merci.
Madame la ministre de la Culture,
"levez-vous, monsieur Hitler,
il y a des personnes qui ont besoin
"d'être brûlées.
Il incombe à chaque Palestinien
"de tuer un Juif
et l'affaire est close."
Non, ce ne sont pas les propos
d'un djihadiste, mais ceux d'un
terroriste reçu en héros à
l'Assemblée nationale par
l'extrême gauche, qui donne des
conférences dans nos prisons avec
l'accord de la Chancellerie.
Ce sont des tweets de journalistes
de la chaîne arabophone de France 24
appelant à la haine des juifs.
Trois des quatre journalistes mis
en cause sont toujours en poste et
rémunérés par les impôts des
Français.
Aucune réaction de votre part face
à ces propos néonazis.
Vous qui vous alarmez pour nos
valeurs républicaines...
Pour vous, tout ce qui est
à droite, intransigeant
avec l'immigration,
est axé d'extrême droite.
En revanche, vous gardez le
silence sur l'antisémitisme niché
durablement au coeur du service
public.
Notre démocratie mérite mieux que
cela.
Vous masquez mal votre
complaisance vis-à-vis d'un nouvel
antisémitisme.
Rappelez-vous les terribles
conséquences de certaines
affaires.
Pourquoi cette hémiplégie
intellectuelle?
N'oubliez jamais que votre
ministère est celui d'André
Malraux.
Mettez le même zèle que celui
déployé contre Vincent Bolloré,
à moins qu'un milliardaire breton
soit plus dangereux pour la
démocratie que les islamistes et
les antisémites.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Isabelle Rome.
- Isabelle Rome: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur le député
Meyer Habib, je reviens
sur les attaques du leader
de La France Insoumise
contre le président du CRIF.
J'entends le Conseil représentatif
des institutions juives de France.
J'étais dimanche à un événement en
souvenir des victimes des crimes
antisémites de l'Etat français
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et pour rendre hommage aux Justes
de France.
Je tiens à redire ici tout mon
soutien aux personnes concernées.
Le gouvernement a lancé un plan
contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme.
Désormais, chaque enfant
effectuera au cours de sa
scolarité une visite d'un lieu
mémoriel.
Quand on a vu Drancy, quand on a
vu Auschwitz, on n'est plus le
même.
On comprend alors ce qu'est
l'antisémitisme, cette idéologie
qui a conduit à la mort de
millions de personnes et on
comprend pourquoi il est indigne
de faire de la petite politique
avec les pires crimes de
l'histoire.
Car oui, l'antisémitisme n'est pas
mort.
Il continue de faire des victimes
en France.
Le gouvernement ne laissera rien
passer.
Nous lutterons toujours sans
relâche contre le racisme,
l'antisémitisme et la haine de
l'autre.
J'invite La France Insoumise et
son leader à un sursaut de
dignité, à nous rejoindre dans ce
combat, non pas seulement pour les
Français juifs, non pas seulement
pour la France, mais pour une
certaine idée de l'humanité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la ministre.
S'il vous plaît, un peu de
silence.
Merci d'écouter les réponses qui
vous sont faites.
S'il vous plaît!
Vous choisissez vos questions, le
gouvernement choisit ses réponses.
Monsieur Olivier Faure pour
le groupe socialiste, vous avez la
parole.
- Olivier Faure: Madame la
Première ministre, nous avons cru
comprendre que vous aviez obtenu
un nouveau sursis.
En effet, puisque tout va si bien,
pourquoi changer de cap?
D'après l'Elysée, l'objectif
des 100 jours d'apaisement
a été tenu.
A ce niveau de déconnexion, on
reste sans voix.
Ces 100 jours viennent après cinq
mois d'un mouvement social inédit
sur nos retraites.
Vous êtes passés en force contre
l'immense majorité de Français.
Qu'avez-vous apaisé?
Les Français souffrent de
l'inflation.
Pourtant, au coeur des vacances,
le tarif de l'électricité va
augmenter de 10% après une
augmentation de 15% en février.
Qu'avez-vous apaisé?
Vos propres experts considèrent
que la richesse insolente des
super-riches devrait être
mobilisée pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique, mais
vous avez refusé d'évoquer le
retour de l'ISF.
Qu'avez-vous apaisé?
L'accès aux soins est devenu
chimérique.
Vous avez rejeté une proposition
pourtant transpartisane portée par
Guillaume Garot sur les déserts
médicaux.
Qu'avez-vous apaisé?
Les journalistes du JDD sont en
grève et interpellent votre
pouvoir pour qu'il intervienne.
Le seul ministre qui a eu le
courage d'affronter la mainmise de
l'extrême droite sur ce journal
n'a reçu aucun soutien de votre
part.
Qu'avez-vous apaisé?
Des Uber Files au fonds de Marlène
Schiappa, plus une semaine sans
que ne soient évoqués les liens
troubles entre gouvernement,
lobbys et intérêts privés.
Vous regardez ailleurs.
Qu'avez-vous apaisé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, mon cher collègue.
Vous avez écoulé votre temps.
La parole est à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Monsieur le
député Olivier Faure, j'ai
l'immense honneur de répondre au
Premier secrétaire d'un parti que
j'ai beaucoup aimé, un parti qui
prônait le travail comme la
première des solidarités, la
sécurité comme la première des
libertés, qui prônait le
renforcement des services publics
et qui promettait aux Français
d'atteindre la transition
énergétique.
Monsieur le député, pendant votre
question, j'ai regardé les votes
qui ont été les vôtres au cours de
ces 100 derniers jours.
Vous avez décidément beaucoup
changé.
Pendant ces 100 jours, nous avons
fait adopter des lois
fondamentales pour les Français,
une loi qui modernise nos armées,
une loi qui modernise notre
justice et lui accorde des moyens
considérables.
Le Parti Socialiste que j'ai
quitté à l'époque aurait voté ce
texte.
Regardez-moi dans les yeux et
dites que je dis faux.
La transition énergétique et la
planification écologique vont nous
permettre d'atteindre un objectif
inespéré sous le quinquennat
Hollande, de réduire de 55% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
cette planification, vous devriez
l'embrasser.
Au-delà des désaccords politiques,
au-delà des effets de tribune,
au-delà des volontés électorales
qui sont votre droit, puisque nous
sommes en démocratie, je vous
assure que vous sortirez grandi à
reconnaître lorsque vous êtes
profondément d'accord avec la
politique qui est conduite.
Pendant ces 100 jours,
qu'avez-vous fait de votre côté?
Qu'avez-vous fait de vos
partenaires qui défilaient pendant
les manifestations interdites?
Qu'avez-vous fait de vos
partenaires qui criaient que tout
le monde déteste la police?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Anne Brugnera.
- Anne Brugnera: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Justice.
En 2022, en France, 3267 personnes
ont trouvé la mort dans un
accident de la route et plus de
16.000 ont été gravement blessées.
92% des accidents mortels sont
causés par un facteur humain.
30%, par une vitesse excessive.
22%, par la conduite sous
l'emprise de l'alcool.
13%, par la conduite sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants.
L'accidentologie et la mortalité
routière doivent baisser.
Les leviers pour agir sont
pluriels: éducation routière,
vérification de l'aptitude à la
conduite, amélioration des
infrastructures et, évidemment,
répression des comportements de
violences routières.
En juin, j'ai déposé avec 38
collègues une proposition de loi
visant à instaurer une infraction
spécifique distincte de l'homicide
involontaire: l'homicide routier.
Cela permet de caractériser le
conducteur dans certaines
circonstances, comme l'usage du
téléphone portable au volant.
Dans de telles circonstances, la
qualification d'homicide
involontaire est inadaptée.
Elle est mal vécue par les
victimes et les familles des
victimes, ce que nous comprenons.
La création de l'homicide routier
vise à réaffirmer la gravité du
comportement des auteurs.
Elle permettra une meilleure
reconnaissance du statut de
victime.
Il convient aussi de parler des
peines.
Au-delà des peines encourues, ce
sont souvent les peines prononcées
qui sont plus clémentes et qui
provoquent la colère de celles et
ceux qui ont perdu un être cher,
fauché sur la route ou le
trottoir.
Madame la Première ministre a
annoncé hier 38 mesures pour
améliorer la sécurité sur la
route, dont la création de
l'homicide routier.
Dès lors, pouvez-vous nous
indiquer quelles seraient les
modalités d'application de cet
homicide en termes de
circonstances et de peines?
Quelle traduction législative
envisagez-vous sur ce sujet?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, ma chère collègue.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti, garde des Sceaux
et ministre de la Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Madame la députée, je veux d'abord
vous remercier pour votre
question.
Je veux souligner votre engagement
sur ce sujet.
Je veux également vous remercier
pour votre proposition de loi.
Je n'oublie pas d'autres députés
qui sont mobilisés sur cette
question.
Notre code pénal, vous l'avez dit,
ne peut pas engendrer une
incompréhension et rajouter de la
souffrance chez les victimes.
C'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons appeler très justement
cette infraction l'"homicide
routier".
Il y a déjà une distinction entre
l'homicide involontaire classique,
puni de trois ans
d'emprisonnement, et l'homicide
perpétré au volant d'un véhicule
en cas d'excès de vitesse, en cas
de prise de substances.
Les pénalités sont aujourd'hui,
selon les circonstances
aggravantes retenues, de 5 ans, 7
ans ou 10 ans.
Nous allons mettre en place cette
mesure et nous allons l'assortir
des autres homicides
involontaires.
Vous avez raison, madame la
députée, mal nommer les choses,
c'est aggraver les malheurs du
monde.
Il faut que les victimes se
retrouvent dans une véritable
sémantique adaptée au chagrin qui
est le leur.
Pour apporter encore plus de
cohérence et de visibilité dans le
code pénal sur les peines
encourues en cas d'homicide
routier, ces dispositions doivent
être intégrées dans ce nouveau
chapitre, qui lui-même s'insère
dans un titre 2 sur les atteintes
à la personne humaine.
Vous savez ma détermination à
lutter contre les comportements
routiers les plus dangereux.
Je sais pouvoir compter sur votre
entière mobilisation pour
qu'ensemble, grâce à votre
initiative, nous puissions changer
la loi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Soumya
Bourouaha pour le groupe GDR.
- Soumya Bourouaha: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre ou
monsieur le ministre de la Santé,
en juin 2020, les députés
communistes et GDR lançaient une
commission d'enquête sur les
conséquences de la Covid sur la
jeunesse.
Les conclusions faisaient état
d'une santé mentale préoccupante
d'une partie de nos enfants et
d'un niveau de prise en charge
nettement insuffisant.
Professionnels de santé, syndicats
étudiants, équipes pédagogiques,
tous alertaient sur ce qui
constituait une bombe à
retardement.
En effet, la pandémie n'a fait
qu'aggraver les phénomènes lourds
préexistants: harcèlements,
violences intrafamiliales,
isolement social, comportement
autodestructeur...
43% des étudiants sont en détresse
psychologique, mais faute de
moyens, faute de personnel dans
les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur, ils ne vont pas
consulter.
Chez les plus petits, la situation
n'est guère mieux, avec 13% des
enfants de primaire présentant au
moins un trouble de santé mentale.
En 10 ans, le nombre de
pédopsychiatres a diminué de plus
d'un tiers alors que les besoins
n'ont jamais été aussi grands.
Ces fragilités psychologiques et
les comportements autodestructeurs
amènent parfois aux violences,
parfois chez de très jeunes
individus.
La répression ne peut constituer
la seule solution.
Ces gens ne trouvent pas
d'accompagnement professionnel.
Quelle sera l'action du
gouvernement afin d'augmenter le
nombre de pédopsychiatres en
créant de nouveaux postes et en
valorisant le choix de la
spécialité de pédopsychiatrie dans
les cursus de formation?
Comment redonner le moyen aux PMI
de mieux accompagner les familles
précaires et de nous doter de tous
les outils nécessaires à la prise
en charge de la santé mentale de
nos enfants?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur François Braun,
ministre de la Santé et de la
Prévention.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, la santé
mentale de nos jeunes est un enjeu
majeur.
C'est un enjeu majeur et
prioritaire, comme l'ont encore
réaffirmé le président de la
République et la Première
ministre.
Un enjeu prioritaire devant la
dégradation de cette santé
mentale, avec encore un signal
fort qui est arrivé récemment sur
l'augmentation de la prescription
de psychotropes chez les plus
jeunes.
Ce signal doit nous interpeller.
Un enjeu majeur car la
pédopsychiatrie est une spécialité
sinistrée par des décennies de
gestion aveugle de nos effectifs
médicaux.
Vous le savez, il faut 10 ans pour
former un médecin, 10 ans pour
"fabriquer" un pédopsychiatre et
c'est bien sûr l'ensemble des
professionnels de la santé mentale
que nous devons appuyer.
La stratégie des 1000 jours pour
les plus jeunes, je n'y reviens
pas, le renforcement, le
déploiement continuent.
Il y a également la création de
postes universitaires en
pédopsychiatrie pour rendre la
filière plus attractive et pour
faciliter la création de
pédopsychiatres.
Il y a aussi la poursuite de Mon
soutien psy.
145.000 patients ont été pris en
charge, dont 20% sont des jeunes.
Puis, il y a le dépistage, qui est
essentiel.
Nous nous appuyons aussi sur les
secouristes en santé mentale, qui
sont 50.000 aujourd'hui.
Nous les déployons, avec le
ministre de l'Education nationale,
dans toutes les écoles, mais aussi
dans le milieu sportif et
associatif.
Enfin, il faut agir sur les bases
de ces difficultés.
C'est le développement des
compétences psychosociales des
enfants.
C'est essentiel dès le plus jeune
âge.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame
Marie-France Lorho pour le
Rassemblement National.
- Marie-France Lorho: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Agriculture.
C'est une production d'excellence
et un fleuron de notre chère
Provence qui m'amènent aujourd'hui
à vous interpeller.
La filière des cerises est en
danger de mort.
Le Vaucluse est le premier
producteur de ce fruit.
Il est directement affecté par le
fléau de certaines mouches qui
ravagent nos cerises.
Il est des caprices de la nature
que nous ne pouvons pas combler.
Il y a aussi un acharnement
idéologique d'une Union Européenne
prête à sacrifier toute une part
de la production alimentaire au
nom d'une pratique supposée
écologiquement vertueuse.
Le 15 décembre 2020, j'avais
interpellé votre prédécesseur par
courrier pour l'informer des
graves dangers encourus par la
filière en cas de
non-renouvellement d'un produit
phytosanitaire irremplaçable
contre les mouches asiatiques.
Certains producteurs ont perdu une
grande partie de leur production.
Les filets placés au-dessus des
productions sont très coûteux et
ne peuvent pas être envisagés
comme le seul outil.
Je m'inquiète également que
l'interdiction de ce produit sur
la filière européenne ne s'adresse
pas aux pays exportateurs de
cerises qui n'ont pas les mêmes
obligations que nos producteurs
français et peuvent vendre à
moindre coût à notre pays des
cerises contenant des
phytosanitaires que nous
bannissons.
C'est de la concurrence déloyale.
Alors que le respect de ces règles
devrait nous enjoindre à produire
et à consommer français, il est
regrettable que favoriser les
circuits étrangers soit plus
onéreux.
Nos agriculteurs baisseront
sûrement les bras et nous perdrons
un des fleurons de notre
agriculture.
Quelles mesures allez-vous prendre
de façon rapide contre ce fléau
pour sauver l'un des phares de
notre production provençale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Marc
Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Vous avez raison, la filière de la
cerise traverse une crise grave,
accentuée cette année par
l'apparition massive d'une mouche
spécifique ainsi que par des
épisodes de grêle.
Que devons-nous faire sur le court
terme?
Nous devons regarder les
dispositifs que nous pouvons
prendre.
Il faut que l'on travaille sur le
moyen et le long terme.
Il faut trouver des alternatives
aux produits phytosanitaires.
J'ai un point de désaccord avec
vous.
Vous parlez de produits qui ont
été interdits pour des sujets de
santé publique, y compris pour les
applicateurs.
La décision n'est pas une
transposition européenne.
C'est une décision européenne qui
s'applique à l'ensemble des pays
européens.
On a besoin d'accélérer sur la
recherche et les innovations.
Vous ne nous trouverez pas sur le
chemin quand il s'agit de
questions d'environnement et de
santé publique.
C'est une voie dangereuse.
On a besoin d'accélérer sur les
alternatives.
Aujourd'hui, c'est quoi?
Il y a un surcoût important pour
la couverture des vergers.
Nous prévoyons donc des moyens
pour accélérer la transition des
vergers et pour donner des
perspectives aux producteurs de
cerises, comme à d'autres secteurs
qui sont touchés par ces
difficultés.
L'urgence, c'est la recherche et
l'innovation pour trouver des
alternatives crédibles
économiquement également.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Martine
Froger pour le groupe LIOT.
- Martine Froger: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
Nous avons été nombreux ici à vous
interpeller sur une
désertification médicale qui
s'aggrave sur de nombreux
territoires et qui se déporte à
présent vers les hôpitaux et leurs
services d'urgence.
Pas un territoire, notamment dans
les zones rurales, n'est épargné
par l'avalanche de défections de
médecins accentuées par une
nouvelle loi.
Tous les clignotants sont au
rouge.
Cette situation devient
insupportable à vivre pour les
patients et insoutenable à porter
pour les élus qui se battent au
quotidien.
C'est le cas en Ariège.
Mon collègue vous interrogeait
encore récemment sur le risque de
fermeture des urgences des deux
centres hospitaliers de l'Ariège.
Depuis, aucune initiative ni
amélioration.
Pire, de nouvelles fermetures de
services arrivent aujourd'hui en
cascade, qualifiées de
"suspensions temporaires".
C'est le cas d'une maternité qui
vient d'annoncer une fermeture de
15 jours.
L'inquiétude et l'incompréhension
sont à leur comble sur un
territoire qui n'en finit pas de
subir cette désertification
galopante.
La situation n'est plus tenable.
Certes, vous avez engagé un
certain nombre de réformes, mais
dans la réalité, nos concitoyens
ne voient aucune amélioration, et
la dégradation de l'offre de soins
s'amplifie.
Pourtant, des solutions existent,
encore faut-il les mettre en
oeuvre.
Je pense notamment à la
mutualisation qui peut se faire à
l'échelle régionale.
Ma question est la suivante: quand
allez-vous enfin entendre les
propositions transpartisanes sur
l'introduction d'une forme de
régulation de l'accès aux soins?
Quelles mesures entendez-vous
prendre à court terme pour assurer
concrètement la continuité du
service public de santé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Merci.
Madame la députée Froger, nous
sommes effectivement d'accord sur
le diagnostic, nous manquons de
professionnels de santé sur
l'ensemble du territoire national,
et pour former un médecin, je le
redis, c'est 10 ans.
Nous n'aurons pas de solution
miracle dans les mois et les
années qui viennent.
Les axes que nous développons sur
ces solutions, c'est redonner plus
de temps aux professionnels, plus
de temps auprès des patients.
Je ne referai pas le débat très
riche que nous avons eu dans cet
hémicycle sur la coercition ou non
à l'installation des médecins
généralistes.
Je rappelle ce que j'ai déjà dit,
elle est contre-productive.
Vous avez parlé des maternités et
des services d'urgence.
Je comprends bien sûr l'enjeu pour
les territoires.
Tout un chacun préfère accoucher
au plus près de chez soi, tout un
chacun préfère être pris en charge
par les urgences au plus proche de
chez soi, mais ma ligne est simple
dans cette organisation, c'est
d'associer sécurité et proximité.
La sécurité, c'est garantir aux
Français qui passent la porte d'un
service d'urgence qu'ils seront
correctement pris en charge.
Il faut garantir aux femmes qui
veulent accoucher des conditions
de sécurité totale pour elles et
leur enfant.
Dans ce cadre-là, nous mettons en
place, avec les élus, à l'échelle
de chaque territoire, les
solutions les plus adaptées en
fonction des moyens dont nous
disposons.
Pour le cas des urgences, les
fermetures sont souvent désaxées
et régulées par l'appel préalable
au 15 pour que l'on donne aux gens
la meilleure solution.
Ce n'est pas d'aller
systématiquement vers les services
d'urgence.
On peut aussi aller voir un
médecin généraliste.
Ca peut se faire aussi à la
campagne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Laurence
Cristol pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Laurence Cristol: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé et de la Prévention.
Depuis un an et pour la première
fois, nous avons un ministre de la
Prévention.
Cela marque une ambition et une
priorité.
Face à l'augmentation des
pathologies chroniques chez nos
jeunes, chez nos aînés en perte
d'autonomie, au travail, à
l'école, les défis sont très
nombreux, et pour cause, la
prévention est à la croisée de
toutes les dimensions de la vie,
de la santé, et les inégalités
territoriales et sociales restent
fortes.
Ceci peut expliquer certaines
impatiences.
Je constate que depuis six ans,
nous avons fait des progrès
considérables, que ce soit sur la
politique de lutte contre le
tabac, la santé sexuelle, la
vaccination ou les 1000 premiers
jours de la vie de l'enfant, mais
si la crise sanitaire a freiné
l'ambition des précédents
gouvernements, les lignes ont
aujourd'hui bougé.
Alors que de nombreux travaux sont
publiés depuis plus d'un an, il
nous faut désormais accélérer.
Je pense en particulier au frein
au développement de l'activité
physique adaptée, aux leviers à
trouver pour mieux lutter contre
l'obésité ou à l'ambition d'une
génération sans tabac, qui doit
nous conduire à mieux réguler les
nouveaux produits conçus par
l'industrie.
Les prochains mois et les
prochaines années doivent amener à
des actions résolues et
structurées.
Ma question est simple: un an
après le début de cette
législature, quel bilan tirez-vous
de votre action et quelles sont
les perspectives de votre
ministère dans les prochains mois
pour accélérer les virages
préventifs de notre société?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, madame la
députée Laurence Cristol, ministre
de la Santé et de la Prévention,
je fais bien entendu de la
prévention un objectif phare de la
politique du gouvernement.
Avec cette prévention, nous
avançons vers une véritable
révolution, un changement de
paradigme voulu par le président
de la République et conduit sous
l'autorité de la Première
ministre.
Ce changement de paradigme, cette
révolution se développe sur deux
axes.
Un premier axe qui est d'abord une
politique d'aller vers nos
concitoyens qui sont le plus loin
des soins.
Nous voulons aussi aller vers la
médiation santé, le déploiement de
centres communautaires, de centres
de consultations avancées.
Un certain nombre de mesures ont
été déployées et vont continuer à
se déployer.
Je reviendrai sur quelques points.
Dans le cadre de la santé
sexuelle, la gratuité des
préservatifs a multiplié par trois
leur utilisation.
La vaccination contre le
papillomavirus va se déployer à
partir de septembre dans les
classes de cinquième auprès de
800.000 élèves.
Nous avons là une occasion
historique de faire disparaître le
cancer du col de l'utérus, qui tue
1000 femmes par an.
Vous avez évoqué le sport-santé.
Nous allons déployer d'autres
maisons sport-santé.
Nous continuons également les
prescriptions de l'activité
physique adaptée.
On a beaucoup parlé de prévention
dans le projet de loi.
Nous débattons sur des rendez-vous
prévention auprès de la tranche
d'âge des 45-50 ans, qui sont les
plus concernés et vers lesquels
nous allons aller en priorité pour
proposer des parcours de santé
complets.
A la rentrée, il y aura aussi un
nouveau plan de lutte contre le
tabac.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Danielle
Simonnet pour La France Insoumise.
- Danielle Simonnet: Chers
collègues, le rapport d'une
commission d'enquête a été rendu
public aujourd'hui.
Il confirme que la plate-forme
américaine Uber est dans l'
fonctionnement.
De nouveaux documents accablants
transmis
par un lanceur d'alerte
a été rendu.
Une note de 2019 du ministère du
Travail démontre que le
gouvernement a pleinement
connaissance de l'étendue du
développement de l'ubérisation
dans les secteurs aussi déchirants
que la restauration et le
funéraire, le BTP, le tourisme,
les auto-écoles, le transport
maritime et j'en passe.
Dans tous ces domaines, la note
est accablante.
Les plates-formes sont hors la loi
et piétinent le code du travail.
Elles piétinent les
réglementations.
Qu'avez-vous fait pour faire
respecter l'Etat de droit?
L'enquête démontre qu'il n'y a eu
aucune inspection politique.
Cela vise uniquement à protéger
les plates-formes du risque de
requalification en salarié au
mépris du droit.
Quel message envoyez-vous aux
entreprises qui subissent ces
concurrences déloyales?
Allez-y, à votre tour, ne payez
pas l'URSSAF et faites de
l'évasion fiscale!
Quel est donc votre projet de
société?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt, ministre du Travail, de
l'Insertion et du Plein emploi.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Madame la députée, que de
mensonges en deux minutes!
Que de mensonges!
Vous dites qu'il y aurait un deal
sacré.
Le rapport de la commission
d'enquête ne montre rien de tout
cela.
Vous dites que les décisions de
justice donnent raison à la thèse
qui est la vôtre.
Il y a un certain nombre de
procédures qui ont été intentées
par des plates-formes.
Moins d'un jugement sur deux a
amené une requalification.
Vous dites que l'organisation du
travail de plates-formes dans
notre pays ne produit aucun droit.
Nous en sommes à cinq accords
collectifs pour protéger les
travailleurs des plates-formes,
pour permettre de fixer un prix
minimum pour organiser la
représentativité.
Vous dites que le gouvernement
fait obstacle à l'adoption d'une
directive européenne.
J'étais présent au Conseil des
ministres et j'ai voté pour la
directive.
Je vais reprendre les mots du
président de la commission
d'enquête.
Il dit que dans votre rôle de
rapporteure, vous avez été parti
pris, que les propositions que
vous faites ne sont que le
copier-coller du programme de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon, que vous avez
eu vous-même une attitude qui
frise avec le complotisme en
audition.
Vous êtes dans l'affirmation et
dans l'incantation.
Le seul objectif que vous
poursuivez, c'est de nourrir une
forme de diversion pour faire
oublier les errements de votre
famille politique.
Votre rapport est creux et c'est
bien là la difficulté pour vous.
Vous pensiez trouver un complot,
vous n'avez trouvé que le droit et
la loi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Isabelle
Valentin pour le
groupe Les Républicains.
- Isabelle Valentin: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Santé et de la Prévention.
Notre système de santé est à bout
de souffle et vous restez aveugle
et sourd.
Nos soignants en établissement et
en ville sont épuisés.
Ils sont démotivés.
Ils ne s'y retrouvent plus dans
leur métier.
Le manque cruel de médecins se
fait sentir dans tous les services
et sur tous les territoires.
La majorité de nos EHPAD sont
déficitaires.
En Haute-Loire, les déficits vont
de 60.000 euros à 130.000 euros
pour 2022.
Concernant 2023, ces chiffres
seront catastrophiques, avec des
déficits en moyenne de 300.000
euros.
C'est accablant, mais personne
dans ce gouvernement ne prend la
mesure du problème.
Face à cela, les établissements de
santé sont forcés de rééquilibrer
leurs comptes au détriment de la
qualité du soin.
Suppressions de postes,
suppressions des postes
d'animateurs, d'ergothérapeutes,
réduction du coût de
l'alimentation...
Malheureusement, la liste est
longue et nos aînés vont en faire
les frais.
Vous le savez, le coût du Ségur et
l'augmentation du point d'indice
ainsi que l'explosion des charges
constituent les principales causes
de cette situation alarmante.
Ces dernières semaines, vous nous
proposez un texte sur le bien
vieillir, mais lancer une
véritable loi sur le grand âge et
l'autonomie reste un choix
politique purement financier qui
vous incombe.
Le texte que vous nous proposez ne
correspond absolument pas à ce
qu'attendent les professionnels de
santé.
Il ne s'agit que d'une coquille
vide, impossible à amender et qui
n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
du bien vieillir.
Les prévisions sont unanimes.
Quid des formations adaptées?
Quelle place voulez-vous donc
donner à nos aînés dans cette
société?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Merci.
Madame la députée, je vous
remercie pour votre question, qui
me permet de rappeler quelle est
l'ambition du gouvernement pour
nos aînés.
Depuis le premier jour de ma
nomination, je suis aux côtés des
établissements pour les soutenir
dans une période particulièrement
difficile, vous l'avez dit, des
difficultés économiques.
C'est pour ça que nous avons dédié
de nombreux millions d'euros
supplémentaires.
Nous prévoyons une augmentation de
budget de plus de 5% pour les
EHPAD.
J'ai demandé aux ARS d'agir avec
les opérateurs pour pouvoir les
soutenir avec des crédits.
Je veux qu'on puisse apporter des
réponses à la hauteur de la
situation à court terme.
A moyen terme, j'ai mis en place
un groupe de travail avec les
départements pour travailler sur
les modèles économiques des EHPAD,
dont les conclusions seront
enrichies par la mission sur le
reste à charge en EHPAD.
Nous sommes à leurs côtés.
Vous faites état de la proposition
de loi du bien vieillir.
Vous savez qu'elle ne reflète pas
toute l'ambition que porte le
gouvernement sur cette question.
J'ai porté une réflexion dédiée au
bien vieillir qui a fait l'objet
de conclusions en avril.
Je présenterai une feuille de
route interministérielle, qui
portera notre ambition pour
adapter la société dans toutes ses
dimensions au défi du
vieillissement que nous devrons
relever tous ensemble.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bertrand
Bouyx pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Bertrand Bouyx: Madame la
présidente, mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse à madame
Catherine Colonna, ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères.
Dans le contexte de guerre au
coeur même de notre vieux
continent suite à l'agression de
la Russie contre l'Ukraine, le
rôle parfois méconnu du Conseil de
l'Europe n'en reste pas moins
essentiel pour les missions de
défense des droits de l'homme.
La Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme, la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme signée par
46 Etats protège aujourd'hui plus
de 700 millions d'Européens.
J'ai l'honneur de présider la
délégation française à l'assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe, et j'en profite pour
saluer tous ses membres pour leur
travail, pour leur engagement, sur
tous les bancs, Assemblée, Sénat.
Merci à eux pour le travail
exemplaire accompli autour de
cette année.
Comme l'a déclaré le président de
la République au quatrième sommet
des chefs d'Etat à Reykjavik le 16
mai dernier, un seul lieu nous
permet d'agir pour la sécurité
démocratique de notre continent:
le Conseil de l'Europe.
A l'occasion de ce sommet
historique, une feuille de route
commune a été tracée.
La France et le Conseil de
l'Europe ont réaffirmé leur
soutien sans faille à l'Ukraine.
Un registre des dommages causés
par l'agression de la Fédération
de la Russie contre l'Ukraine a
été créé.
La volonté politique est
aujourd'hui de créer un tribunal
spécial international pour juger
les crimes de guerre commis par la
Russie.
Dans la ville martyre d'Irpin,
nous avons pu constater les
blessures infligées par les
soldats russes au peuple
ukrainien.
Monsieur le ministre, pouvez-vous
nous détailler devant la
représentation nationale
quelle part entend prendre
la France
dans ce processus visant
à faire reconnaître les crimes
de la Russie et permettre
l'indemnisation des victimes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Monsieur le
député Bertrand Bouyx, la France
réitère sa condamnation de
l'agression injustifiée et
illégale de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine.
La Russie doit rendre des comptes
et nous soutiendrons l'Ukraine
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra.
C'est le message constant qui est
ressorti des rendez-vous
internationaux qui se sont succédé
au cours des dernières
semaines, qu'il s'agisse du sommet
du G7, du Conseil européen ou du
sommet de l'OTAN.
Nous avons saisi sans délai...
Nous avons apporté sans délai,
pardon, un soutien humain et
financier aux juridictions
ukrainiennes et à la Cour pénale
internationale, pour leurs
enquêtes sur les crimes commis par
la Russie contre les victimes
ukrainiennes.
Comme l'a rappelé la ministre
Catherine Colonna hier aux Nations
Unies, à l'occasion du 25e
anniversaire du statut de Rome, il
ne peut pas y avoir de paix sans
justice, ni en Ukraine, ni nulle
part ailleurs.
Vous évoquez en particulier
l'action du Conseil de l'Europe,
et je voudrais rendre hommage à la
délégation française que vous
présidez à l'assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe.
Le Conseil de l'Europe a su agir
vite en excluant la Russie.
Il s'est porté sans délai aux
côtés de l'Ukraine pour
accompagner sa résilience et ses
efforts, pour renforcer encore
l'état de droit et l'aider à
lutter contre l'impunité des
criminels russes.
Lors du sommet de Reykjavik,
les 16 et 17 mai, auquel
le président de la République
a assisté, le Conseil de l'Europe
a marqué à nouveau
son soutien à l'Ukraine
en créant un registre des dommages
causés par l'agression russe.
Ce registre permettra de recenser
les dommages, pertes ou préjudices
subis par les victimes de la
Russie contre l'Ukraine.
Tous les pays peuvent y adhérer, y
compris ceux qui ne sont pas
membres du Conseil de l'Europe.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Anna Pic.
- Anna Pic: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'Etat auprès du
ministre des Armées chargée de la
Jeunesse et du Service national
universel.
Face à nos interrogations et
réticences, vous nous avez invités
à nous rendre sur le terrain pour
voir de nos propres yeux la
réalité du SNU.
J'ai donc suivi votre
recommandation et le constat est
déroutant.
Je veux croire que ce n'est pas
partout comme ça.
Nous sommes loin des enjeux
proclamés à grand renfort de
communication tels que le
développement de la mixité
sociale, l'appréhension des
valeurs de la République et
l'engagement au service de la
nation.
J'ai été muette pendant une
minute.
Je reprends ici les propos du
premier tuteur rencontré qui, à la
vue de ma carte de visite, s'est
exclamé: "Ah, je connais
l'Assemblée nationale,
je l'ai visitée.
Je n'ai pas voté aux législatives.
Moi, je ne vote que pour les
présidentielles."
La responsable du séjour nous
explique ensuite
les activités: levée de couleurs,
baby-foot, visites culturelles et
intervention de l'armée ou de la
gendarmerie.
Les objectifs présentés en réalité
sont assez similaires à ceux déjà
validés par l'ensemble des élèves
en fin de classe de 3e, à ceci
près qu'ils ne sont pas transmis
par des gens formés à cela
et que le budget qui y est consacré
est particulièrement important.
On m'a annoncé 700 euros par jeune
hors hébergement et restauration.
A mon interrogation à propos
des attentes des jeunes et du sens
qu'ils mettent dans les symboles
mis en avant comme le drapeau ou
la Marseillaise, le silence de
l'encadrant est à la fois profond
et gêné.
"On parle des valeurs de la
France."
En fait, on évoque la devise
nationale, mais dans le désordre
et avec la plus grande hésitation.
J'ai quitté le site assez
consternée, avec le ressenti que
le SNU s'apparente à une colonie
de vacances inadaptée aux enjeux.
Madame la ministre, ne serait-il
pas temps, au regard des
dispositifs alloués, d'abandonner
ce dispositif aussi coûteux
qu'inadapté et de transférer les
crédits à l'Education nationale et
à l'éducation populaire, acteurs
plus à même de répondre aux
enjeux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Sarah El Haïry.
- Sarah El Haïry: Madame la
députée Anna Pic, je vous remercie
d'avoir pris le temps d'aller à la
rencontre de cette jeunesse
engagée qui a fait le choix de
prendre 15 jours pour développer
son esprit civique, citoyen, de
vivre des temps de patriotisme.
Je suis particulièrement heureuse
de cette démarche de votre part,
parce qu'elle a l'honnêteté
d'aller à leur rencontre, de
découvrir aussi que 57% des jeunes
qui ont fait le SNU sont des
jeunes filles, que plus de 6% sont
des jeunes qui viennent des
quartiers populaires.
En réalité, lever le drapeau
français est une chance, cela crée
de l'unité.
Cela vient en complémentarité avec
les travaux qui sont menés par les
enseignants au sein de l'Education
nationale.
Il n'y a pas d'investissement
excessif pour notre jeunesse.
Des parlementaires de l'ensemble
des bancs...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame Sophia
Chikirou, vous pouvez vous taire
et laisser parler la ministre?
- Sarah El Haïry: Des députés de
l'ensemble des bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale sont partis
à la rencontre de ces jeunes en
SNU.
Il y a 10.000 jeunes sur liste
d'attente.
D'année en année, c'est un succès
qui prend tranquillement et qui
fait ses preuves.
Il n'y a rien de plus fort, en
tout cas à mes yeux, que de voir
une jeunesse qui n'était jamais
sortie de son département oser
quitter son département, être dans
un dortoir, manger la même chose,
découvrir...
Madame la députée, plus que
jamais, un tiers des encadrants
du service national universel
viennent de l'éducation populaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la ministre.
La parole est à Christophe
Plassard.
- Christophe Plassard: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Monsieur le ministre, lundi 4
septembre prochain, 12 millions
d'élèves rentreront sur les bancs
de l'école, dont plus de 46.000 en
Charente-Maritime, soit une baisse
d'environ 700 élèves sur une
année.
Cela entraîne une recomposition
importante des cartes scolaires,
notamment en zone rurale,
que nous avons fragilisée
démographiquement et dont il faut
renforcer l'attractivité.
Cette baisse du nombre d'enfants
entraîne une baisse logique du
nombre de classes.
Attention cependant à ce que ce ne
soit pas synonyme de baisse de la
qualité de l'enseignement, tout
particulièrement en zone rurale.
Au niveau local, les fermetures de
classes peuvent aboutir à une
surpopulation des classes
restantes, entraînant la baisse du
niveau d'enseignement et une
détérioration de la qualité de vie
des enfants.
Même si de nombreuses mesures sont
déployées pour cette rentrée,
comme l'élargissement de
l'expérimentation territoires
éducatifs ruraux, le dédoublement
des classes dans les zones
quartiers prioritaires des
politiques de la ville a prouvé sa
pertinence.
Peut-on envisager son application
dans la ruralité?
Les problématiques de recrutement
peuvent faire craindre un manque
d'enseignants.
Dans cette optique, le
gouvernement a apporté des mesures
volontaristes ces deux dernières
années, notamment une
revalorisation inédite des
salaires des professeurs.
Pourriez-vous nous préciser
comment le gouvernement accompagne
les académies pour s'assurer que
cette rentrée scolaire se déroule
dans les meilleures conditions
possibles?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Monsieur le député
Christophe Plassard, les
territoires ruraux, en
prolongement de votre question,
ont une double caractéristique:
l'éloignement et la faible densité
d'une part, et d'autre part, la
baisse des effectifs scolaires.
Nous nous sommes engagés à ce que
le taux d'encadrement s'améliore.
Il va légèrement s'améliorer, en
passant sous les 22 élèves par
classe dans votre département.
Nous devons faire plus,
incontestablement.
C'est tout l'objet du plan
ruralité qui a été annoncé par la
Première ministre il y a quelques
mois.
Les maires des communes rurales
demandent de la visibilité et
demandent à ce que la carte
scolaire ne soit pas modifiée en
février pour la rentrée.
Nous nous engageons donc à ce
qu'une instance de concertation
puisse regarder cette carte
scolaire sur trois ans, en tenant
compte des mouvements annuels de
population.
Il ne s'agit pas de geler la carte
scolaire, mais de donner de la
visibilité aux maires, et c'est
bien ce qu'ils réclament.
Vous faites allusion à la perte
d'attractivité du métier, à
laquelle nous répondons d'abord
par des hausses significatives de
salaire, entre 8 et 11% pour les 7
premiers échelons de carrière.
Je note que le nombre d'admis au
concours s'améliore cette année:
plus 8,2%.
Nous avons encore du chemin à
parcourir, mais cela permet de
préparer la rentrée dans des
conditions qui s'annoncent
satisfaisantes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Andrée Taurinya.
- Andrée Taurinya: Monsieur le
ministre des Solidarités, en
France, 40% des gens ne partiront
pas en vacances cette année, 63%
d'ouvriers, c'est trois fois plus
que les cadres.
La raison: la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat.
Il y a aussi l'augmentation des
loyers, celle des prix des
produits de première nécessité que
vous et le RN avez refusé de
bloquer quand nous vous le
proposions.
C'est les salaires que vous n'avez
pas voulu augmenter pour rattraper
l'inflation.
Pour tous ceux vivant dans la
précarité, pour les enfants qui
n'ont pas la chance d'avoir des
grands-parents à la retraite, et
ceux-là seront encore plus
nombreux l'an prochain à cause de
votre réforme, les vacances, ça
reste du rêve.
Les centres sociaux permettraient
d'adoucir leur été.
Toute l'année, ces espaces créent
du lien social, prennent le relais
des services publics que vous
détruisez petit à petit.
Ils permettent l'expression
pacifique de la parole des
citoyens.
Ils offrent des activités
culturelles et sportives aux
enfants comme aux parents.
Précieux, ils deviennent
indispensables pendant les
vacances scolaires.
Pour ces enfants et ces ados
contraints de rester chez eux par
vos choix politiques, c'est
essentiel.
Mais les centres sociaux crient au
secours.
Ils sont fragilisés par un
sous-financement chronique, par
votre logique délétère d'appels à
projets et par une crise profonde
des métiers du secteur social.
Ils subissent aussi de plein fouet
les conséquences de l'inflation.
Ils ont déjà raboté tout ce qui
pouvait être raboté.
Aujourd'hui, on arrive à l'os.
La Fédération des centres sociaux
de la Loire a réalisé une
projection comptable sur l'année
prochaine.
Le constat est dramatique: sans un
soutien massif au niveau national,
de nombreux centres sociaux vont
baisser le rideau.
Ceux des quartiers les plus
fragiles seront les premiers
concernés.
Pouvez-vous clarifier la ligne de
la convention d'objectifs et de
gestion de la Sécurité sociale en
matière d'augmentation des
prestations des centres sociaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Merci.
Madame la députée Andrée Taurinya,
en tant que ministre en charge de
la Petite enfance et des Familles,
je ne peux que partager avec vous
la pensée que vous avez pour
toutes ces familles qui partent
aujourd'hui en vacances et celles
qui ne le pourront malheureusement
pas.
Il ne faut jamais se résigner.
Je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous,
parce que nous agissons.
Cette année encore, avec les
collectivités locales et avec les
acteurs associatifs, le
gouvernement fera en sorte d'aider
autant d'enfants que possible.
C'est un enjeu d'équilibre entre
vie personnelle et professionnelle
pour les parents, et d'accès pour
les enfants à des temps de
sociabilisation.
A ce titre, la nouvelle convention
que j'ai signée il y a quelques
jours prévoit un effort
significatif en faveur de l'accès
aux vacances.
Les CAF vont renforcer leur
accueil,
avec plus de 12% d'heures
d'accueil financées.
C'est un vrai investissement.
C'est historique.
Pour que tous les enfants puissent
être accueillis sans distinction,
le bonus inclusif a été mis en
place.
C'était une annonce forte portée
par la conférence nationale du
handicap.
Ces efforts viennent compléter
l'action de mes collègues, avec
notamment les colos apprenantes.
Vous m'interrogez sur le soutien
aux centres sociaux.
Ces centres sociaux sont au coeur
de la nouvelle convention
d'objectifs et de gestion.
Les CAF monteront plus de 600
nouveaux centres sociaux entre
2023 et 2027, tout en renforçant
leurs financements.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Francis Dubois.
- Francis Dubois: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la Souveraineté alimentaire.
"Mangez des pommes", aimait
répéter Jacques Chirac en vantant
la pomme corrézienne.
Or la pomme française est en
danger.
La filière est attaquée de toutes
parts, et les nuisibles sont
pluriels.
D'abord, des invasions massives
de pucerons dévastent nos vergers.
De plus, les normes françaises
impactent nos cultivateurs, alors
que l'Union Européenne réglemente
l'utilisation et autorise une
liste de produits phytosanitaires.
La France interdit et pénalise les
producteurs qui ne disposent que
de traitements phytosanitaires
inefficaces dont les coûts de
production sont multipliés par
trois.
Notre souveraineté alimentaire
passe par des règles homogènes.
Face aux pucerons, le verger
français doit être traité comme le
verger italien ou polonais.
Nous ne pouvons laisser nos
agriculteurs dans le désarroi.
Même en Corrèze, les grossistes
importent massivement de Pologne
des pommes traitées avec des
produits interdits en France,
servies ensuite dans les assiettes
de nos collégiens et de nos aînés
en EHPAD.
Nous marchons sur la tête.
Les pommes de la discorde sont
légion.
Il y a aussi des nuisibles
écologistes ravageurs.
La semaine dernière encore, dans
le Tarn, plus de 9000 pommiers ont
été arrachés, saccagés.
Dans quel monde vit-on?
90% d'un verger détruit par des
commandos écologistes, alors que
face à la dureté du marché bio, où
seule la moitié de la production
des pommes bio est valorisée, les
producteurs se trouvent contraints
de s'adapter en revenant à une
agriculture conventionnelle.
Sur la question des traitements,
appliquons les règles de l'UE
et stoppons la surenchère punitive
à la française.
Proposons sans délai des
engagements concrets et durables à
nos producteurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Monsieur le
député, la terre de Corrèze vante
la pomme, vous avez raison.
Je voudrais dénoncer comme vous
les actes de destruction de biens
d'autrui, revendiqués sous le
couvert de l'anonymat.
Cela pose question sur l'intention
finale de ces personnes.
La justice est saisie.
Tout cela procède d'un certain
nombre de gens qui viennent
opposer les agricultures, le
modèle conventionnel et le modèle
bio.
Quand les mots sont violents,
la violence naît.
Attention à ce que l'on dit
et à la nécessité de défendre
toutes les agricultures.
Vous avez raison de raisonner en
européen.
Il nous faut des clauses
européennes.
Nous devons sortir d'une filière.
Il faut avoir une planification
sur les molécules.
Il faut regarder les usages et
mettre des moyens sur la recherche
et l'innovation, ce que nous
faisons au travers du plan France
2030.
C'est aussi un acte de
consommateur.
Nous travaillons dans les
cantines.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Pascal Lavergne.
- Pascal Lavergne: Mes chers
collègues, ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la Santé.
Depuis plusieurs jours, les
producteurs de vin, de spiritueux
et de bières s'inquiètent d'une
modification de la fiscalité sur
l'alcool, et notamment d'un
relèvement des droits d'accise.
La filière vin et des spiritueux
ainsi que la bière représente 50
milliards de chiffres d'affaires.
Ce secteur d'excellence français
est le second contributeur à la
balance commerciale, avec un solde
commercial de près de 16
milliards.
La viticulture, c'est près de
650.000 emplois dans les
territoires non délocalisables.
En nombre de brasseries, la France
est le premier en Europe et le
deuxième dans le monde.
La viticulture, la brasserie, les
spiritueux sont des secteurs en
pleine crise de compétitivité.
En effet, le contexte actuel est
particulièrement difficile pour
eux: crise géopolitique, crise
sanitaire, aléas climatiques, prix
de l'énergie, inflation sur les
matières sèches.
Ces difficultés s'observent
partout.
Dans mon département de Gironde,
aujourd'hui, ces difficultés sont
exacerbées en raison des ravages
du mildiou.
Cela fragilise l'ensemble d'un
secteur et l'augmentation de la
fiscalité aggraverait une
situation économique déjà
dégradée.
Depuis 2017, la majorité oeuvre
pour la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et de nos filières.
Une augmentation de la fiscalité
viendrait mettre sous pression une
des rares filières exportatrices.
Ce soutien de la majorité à cette
filière ne vaut pas négociation
des enjeux de santé publique liés
à la consommation d'alcool.
Aujourd'hui, tous les indicateurs
de santé publique sont orientés à
la baisse.
La France, qui était deuxième
consommateur en 2016,
est aujourd'hui 13e.
Envisagez-vous une taxation sur
les alcools?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à François Braun.
- François Braun: Merci.
Monsieur le député Pascal
Lavergne, je vous remercie pour
votre question qui va me permettre
de clarifier nos pistes de travail
en la matière.
Je tiens d'abord à saluer le
travail qui a été conduit par les
députés de la commission des
Affaires sociales.
Un rapport a été produit sur ce
sujet, qui fournit plusieurs
pistes de réflexion
intéressantes.
Notre combat n'est pas contre une
filière, absolument pas.
Je vous rejoins dans le soutien à
avoir pour nos viticulteurs et nos
brasseurs.
J'ai eu l'occasion de me rendre
récemment dans votre belle
circonscription.
Notre combat est contre la
consommation excessive d'alcool.
Notre approche se base sur la
prévention, sur la modération.
C'est avant tout un enjeu de santé
publique.
La consommation excessive
d'alcool, et j'insiste bien sur le
terme "excessive", est encore
responsable dans notre pays de
41.000 morts par an.
Nous avons ainsi une action
générale de prévention.
Je pense aux campagnes de
prévention régulières, notamment
ciblées vers les jeunes et les
milieux festifs, et je pense aussi
à ce que nous déployons pour
accompagner d'un point de vue
psychologique les victimes, car ce
sont des victimes de ces
addictions.
On observe des résultats positifs
sur la consommation d'alcool
mensuelle, qui a reculé de 13
points en 10 ans chez les jeunes
de 17 ans, par exemple.
Comme chaque année, le PLFSS sera
l'occasion d'un débat sur notre
niveau de prélèvements sur
certains produits, dont les
produits à base d'alcool.
Je pense essentiellement aux
alcools forts.
Cette réflexion associera
l'ensemble des parties prenantes,
les parlementaires de la majorité
comme de l'opposition, comme j'ai
déjà commencé à le faire.
Nous aurons ainsi à la rentrée des
consultations larges sur le PLFSS.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Pierre
Morel-A-L'Huissier.
- Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier:
Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le garde des Sceaux.
"Ma chérie, dans quelques jours,
cela fera 10 ans qu'un fou du
volant t'a pris ta vie, a brisé la
nôtre, celle de ton petit frère et
celle de tous ceux qui t'aiment et
qui ne t'oublient pas.
10 ans que je me bats pour
qu'enfin soit reconnu l'homicide
routier.
10 ans.
Alors aujourd'hui, je pense à toi
et à toutes ces victimes
innocentes de chauffards de la
route.
Je pense à tous ces parents qui
souffrent et à tous nos amis.
On ne lâchera rien.
Maman."
Des témoignages comme celui-ci,
chaque député peut en recevoir.
On ne peut rester insensible à de
telles situations qui provoquent
le décès d'un proche, d'un père,
d'une mère, d'un enfant, ou des
blessures qui impactent
tout au long d'une vie
à cause d'un comportement
routier irresponsable.
Nous sommes plusieurs
parlementaires de tous bords
politiques à nous être emparés de
ce sujet, en lien avec plusieurs
associations de victimes. Je
vous demande de permettre un
débat parlementaire le plus ouvert
qui soit, allant parfois au-delà
des mesures annoncées, afin de
présenter et voter un texte
consensuel.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Monsieur le
député Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier,
vous appelez de vos voeux un débat
parlementaire, vous l'aurez.
C'est une certitude.
Vous êtes plusieurs à être engagés
sur ce sujet de longue date.
Anne Brugnera, vous-même, et
d'autres parlementaires.
Madame la Première ministre a
annoncé hier que nous allions
donner à cette terrible infraction
le nom qui est le bon, et nous
allons créer une infraction
autonome, mais il y a d'autres
mesures dont je veux rapidement
vous parler, que je porte avec
Gérald Darmanin, le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer.
D'abord, la contravention d'excès
de grande vitesse
va devenir un délit.
C'est 41.000 excès de grande
vitesse de 2019 et 72.000 en 2022.
Vous savez ma détermination à
lutter contre les comportements
routiers les plus dangereux.
Sans attendre ces évolutions
législatives auxquelles nous nous
associerons avec vous, je voudrais
vous dire que je prends dans les
prochains jours une circulaire de
politique pénale en matière
routière dans la droite ligne du
comité interministériel.
Je souhaite que l'on prenne en
compte les victimes mieux que nous
le faisons, et en particulier
s'agissant de l'information qui
leur est due.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier: Merci
pour le débat.
Je connais votre sensibilité, et
je ne doute pas que nous ferons
oeuvre utile.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Sébastien Peytavie.
- Sébastien Peytavie: Mes chers
collègues, encore aujourd'hui, le
gouvernement fait peser sur les
épaules des plus précaires le
poids de son incapacité à prévoir
les crises futures.
Face à ces 10% d'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie annoncés,
seulement 4% d'augmentation du
SMIC.
Les pensions, 0,8%.
Le point d'indice des
fonctionnaires, 1,5%.
Qui supporte l'inflation, la
réforme des retraites?
Ce sont les plus précaires, ceux à
qui vous demandez encore
aujourd'hui injustement des
efforts.
Gouverner, c'est anticiper.
Nous vous avions déjà alerté lors
de la mise en place du bouclier
tarifaire.
Cette crise n'est ni la première
ni la dernière.
Les Français n'ont pas à payer
votre manque d'investissement dans
les énergies renouvelables et dans
l'efficacité énergétique.
Le Grenelle de l'environnement a
fixé l'objectif de 38% de baisse
des consommations dans le bâtiment
pour 2020.
Nous n'en sommes qu'à 1%
aujourd'hui.
Le résultat, c'est une
augmentation de 150 euros par an
qui va obliger les familles les
plus modestes à faire des
arbitrages entre manger, offrir
des vacances à leurs enfants ou
payer des factures d'électricité.
Vous souhaitez faire 14 milliards
d'euros d'économies.
Au lieu de pénaliser les plus
pauvres, vous auriez pu choisir
d'exclure du bouclier tarifaire
les 20% les plus riches qui sont
ceux qui consomment le plus.
Vous auriez pu choisir de mettre
en place un bouclier tarifaire
juste avec des tarifs progressifs
sur l'énergie pour garantir les
premiers kilowattheures pour les
besoins vitaux.
Vous auriez pu faire payer plus
cher l'énergie dite superflue.
Quelle option avez-vous donc à
nous offrir pour une énergie
accessible et durable face aux
crises à venir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher, ministre de la
Transition énergétique.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Monsieur
le député, vous vous inquiétez
d'une hausse de 10% des prix de
l'électricité, mais dois-je vous
rappeler que c'est vous et votre
groupe qui n'avez pas voté le
bouclier énergétique qui a permis
de limiter les hausses de tarifs
pour les particuliers et pour les
entreprises?
Dois-je aussi vous rappeler que
c'est vous et votre groupe qui
n'avez pas voté la loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables?
Dois-je également vous rappeler
que c'est vous et votre groupe qui
n'avez pas voté la loi
d'accélération de l'énergie
nucléaire parce que, comme vous le
savez, il faudra à la fois du
nucléaire et des énergies
renouvelables pour permettre à
notre pays d'avoir une énergie
abondante, pas chère, produite sur
notre territoire, au bénéfice des
industries et qui permette de
créer de l'emploi et c'est
exactement la politique que nous
menons et la stratégie que nous
avons.
Dois-je également vous rappeler
que nous n'avons pas entendu
beaucoup de soutien sur le plan
sobriété qui a permis à l'ensemble
des grandes entreprises, des
grandes administrations, des
grandes collectivités locales de
réduire leur consommation
d'énergie et qui nous a permis de
baisser nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de 2,7% l'année
dernière au premier trimestre?
Quand vous mettrez en cohérence
vos actes et vos paroles avec vos
votes à l'Assemblée nationale, on
pourra continuer à discuter.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Thibaut
François pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Thibaut François: Je vous
remercie.
Chers collègues, ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre, qui vient de partir.
Le 14 juillet dernier, une
économiste américaine a été nommée
à la Commission européenne.
La commission de Bruxelles est
étrangère à toute idée de
souveraineté, qu'elle soit
nationale ou européenne.
Ancienne consultante de géants des
numériques comme Microsoft ou
Apple, elle a servi également dans
l'administration Obama.
Comment imaginer que cette
lobbyiste américaine défende
l'intérêt des Européens contre
l'influence des GAFAM quand nous
savons que toutes ces entreprises
américaines la feront tomber pour
espionnage économique?
Le destin des GAFAM est aux mains
des GAFAM eux-mêmes.
Ursula von der Leyen outrepasse
ses prérogatives.
Nombre de gouvernements ont
pourtant dénoncé ces dérives de la
Commission, qui fait souvent fi de
la volonté des peuples européens
et de leurs intérêts, comme le
démontre cette nouvelle
nomination.
Ce mépris envers les
Etats-membres, on nous dit que la
décision a été prise et qu'il n'y
a aucune raison de la
reconsidérer.
Allez-vous réellement vous opposer
à cette nomination ou allez-vous
continuer à laisser la Commission
européenne dicter ses règles?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: la parole est
à monsieur Olivier Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur le député, je voudrais
associer à ma réponse le ministre
délégué Jean-Noël Barrot et vous
dire que j'ai déjà répondu au
député monsieur Philippe Latombe
sur ce sujet.
Je voudrais vous redire la
position du gouvernement.
Oui, ce profil pose question, tant
sur la question des conflits
d'intérêts que sur celle de la
souveraineté européenne.
Vous avez raison sur la
Je voudrais redire qu'il s'agit
d'un processus certes interne à la
Commission européenne, mais dont
nous demandons le réexamen de la
décision.
Nous l'avons expressément invitée
à le faire.
Je note aussi, et c'est très
clair, que le Parlement européen
se saisit de la question et
auditionne aujourd'hui même la
commissaire concernée.
Pourquoi le Parlement européen
fait cela?
L'idée de souveraineté européenne
portée par le président de la
République est poussée par la
France depuis six ans et est
désormais majoritaire en Europe.
La défense des intérêts
stratégiques de l'Union
Européenne, de nos entreprises et
de nos emplois est désormais une
boussole de notre action au niveau
européen.
Nous attendons que la Commission
européenne suive cette voie et
réexamine la décision de cette
nomination.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Thibaut François: En effet,
depuis trop longtemps, vous
attendez la Commission européenne
qui ne représente personne alors
que les pouvoirs devraient être au
Conseil européen qui représente
les peuples.
Vous venez de dire que vous aviez
une majorité à la Commission
européenne, mais vous avez perdu
les élections en 2019 et je peux
vous prédire que Jordan Bardella
va gagner les prochaines
élections.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Mohamed Laqhila pour le
groupe démocrate.
- Mohamed Laqhila: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Action et des Comptes
publics, monsieur Gabriel Attal.
Nous entamons une nouvelle phase
de gestion de nos finances
publiques.
Je tiens à saluer les dialogues
avec Bercy avec toutes les
sensibilités parlementaires.
Le "quoi qu'il en coûte" a permis
de préserver des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises et
d'emplois.
Les mesures d'urgence ont répondu
à l'inflation, en premier lieu le
bouclier tarifaire, qui a permis
de limiter l'inflation.
Nous devons rationaliser les
dépenses publiques.
Une France trop endettée, c'est
une France qui abandonne son
avenir.
Vous avez présenté en fin de
semaine un document sur les
plafonds des dépenses de l'Etat
pour 2024 avec des économies
principalement sur la fin des
mesures d'urgence, nous le
saluons.
Ces seuls efforts ne suffiront pas
à rétablir durablement nos
finances publiques.
Un outil essentiel est la lutte
contre la fraude contre toutes les
fraudes.
C'est nécessaire pour garantir la
justice sociale, et en la matière,
nous n'avons pas à rougir de nos
efforts.
A ce titre, nous travaillons
depuis des mois avec vous sur la
fraude à la TVA, première source
potentielle de fraude.
Par des outils simples, nous
voulons y répondre efficacement
avec un fort effet de levier
potentiel et donc des perspectives
de financement pour nos enjeux
d'aujourd'hui et de demain.
Entre autres, l'adaptation au
changement climatique, la santé de
nos concitoyens et
l'accompagnement de chacun vers un
logement digne et durable.
Pouvez-vous nous préciser où en
est la phase de lancement de la
facturation électronique?
Nos administrations sont-elles
prêtes à faire face à cette
nouvelle obligation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, d'abord, je
vous remercie d'avoir mentionné
les dialogues de Bercy.
J'ai souhaité relancer cette
initiative cette année.
Je crois profondément au dialogue,
au-delà des clivages politiques,
et je ne sais pas ce qui résonnera
du vote des uns et des autres.
Vous abordez la question de la
lutte contre la fraude et ce sera
un chapitre majeur du projet de
loi de finances et un chapitre
majeur du projet de loi de
financement de la Sécurité
sociale.
Quand on parle de fraude fiscale,
la fraude fiscale pour laquelle
nous avons une évaluation la plus
solide, c'est la fraude à la TVA.
Elle est estimée à 20 milliards
d'euros par an.
On voit qu'on doit être beaucoup
plus efficace sur ce sujet.
Dès la prochaine loi, il y aura un
bon nombre de mesures sur ce
sujet.
Je souhaite également qu'il y ait
une mesure s'agissant de la vente
sur Internet dans laquelle le
vendeur ne s'occupe que de la
vente du produit.
Cela se prête à des évitements de
la TVA.
Il y aura une mesure pour réformer
les règles de la TVA à
l'importation.
Ensuite, les relations entre
assujettis.
Vous avez fait beaucoup de
propositions sur ce sujet.
Je souhaite que l'on avance avec
ce que la directive TVA nous
permet de faire.
Enfin, le chantier majeur, c'est
la facturation électronique.
Elle doit entrer en vigueur
progressivement à l'horizon 2026,
et nous allons continuer à
travailler pour que le calendrier
soit soutenable.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Steve
Chailloux pour le groupe GDR.
- Steve Chailloux: Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres, chers
collègues, je m'adresse au
ministre des Armées.
Monsieur le ministre, j'attire
votre attention sur la situation
de détresse des blessés de guerre
en Polynésie.
Pour préserver ses intérêts dans
le monde, la France a été
contrainte de les jeter dans la
bataille.
Ce soutien est nécessaire pour
compenser la perte d'autonomie que
provoquent leurs blessures.
Il s'agit là d'une contrepartie
évidente au sacrifice qu'ils ont
consenti pour la nation.
Or, en Polynésie, une telle
contrepartie s'avère défaillante.
Ce sont les cellules d'aide des
trois armées qui ont pour mission
d'assurer un tel suivi, mais
lorsque ces derniers sortent de
l'Hexagone et regagnent
physiquement la Polynésie, leur
situation semble échapper à la
compétences desdites cellules.
L'éloignement géographique est la
principale cause.
Les cellules d'aide ne connaissent
en Polynésie aucun équivalent en
termes de moyens.
Lorsque le militaire blessé est
radié des contrôles de l'armée,
il a du mal à un retour à
l'emploi.
En Polynésie, l'accompagnement de
ces militaires est lacunaire et ce
sont donc les blessés eux-mêmes
qui finissent par en souffrir.
La Polynésie offre pourtant chaque
année à la France près de 600 de
ses enfants pour alimenter
l'armée.
Une telle souffrance est
inacceptable.
Ma question est donc simple:
quelles actions l'Etat français
compte-t-il mettre en place pour
résoudre cette situation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Sarah El
Haïry.
- Sarah El Haïry: Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur le député, je voudrais
d'abord présenter les excuses du
ministre des Armées, qui est à
l'étranger.
Sa réponse lui tenait à coeur.
Vous avez raison, des droits pour
leur sacrifice, bien sûr, pour
l'ensemble de nos blessés.
Il y a des spécificités dans nos
outre-mer.
C'est une réalité.
Vous évoquez plusieurs points.
Je pense à l'accompagnement
physique et à l'éloignement a
posteriori du retour de
l'Hexagone.
Tous les aspects du parcours
doivent être garantis.
Le premier d'entre eux, c'est
l'accès au droit.
On sait à quel point cet accès au
droit a besoin du plan qui a été
annoncé par ma collègue le 10 mai
dernier.
Il a été renforcé par les propos
du président de la République le
13 juillet dernier.
Cet accompagnement, nous leur
devons.
Le premier axe de ce plan, c'est
d'abord faciliter cet accès.
Le président a aussi rappelé que
plus que jamais, la pension
militaire d'invalidité devait être
facilitée.
Elle sera automatisée et rendue en
format numérique pour faciliter
son accès.
Ce sera effectif bientôt.
Pour les blessures psychiques, on
sait à quel point elles sont
importantes, la téléexpertise va
être mise en place pour éviter les
déplacements inutiles.
Les cellules d'aide vont être
densifiées.
Il y aura un meilleur
accompagnement en fonction de la
réalité du tissu local.
Un investissement financier est
essentiel.
16 millions d'euros pour renforcer
ces cellules.
C'est
d'abord l'humain qui accompagne
avec un effort particulier sur les
outre-mer.
Six au moins seront à destination
des outre-mer.
Il y a également des maisons
spécifiques qui seront développées
pour les outre-mer.
On sait que ça a fait ses preuves.
Vous pouvez compter sur la
mobilisation de l'ensemble de la
maison des armées.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Adrien
Quatennens pour La France
Insoumise.
- Adrien Quatennens: Madame la
Première ministre, ceux qui ont
pris tout le plat dans leur
assiette, laissant les assiettes
des autres vides et qui, ayant
tout, disent avec une bonne
figure, une bonne conscience:
"Nous qui avons tout, on est pour
la paix.
Les premiers provocateurs, c'est
vous."
Ces mots, ce sont les mots de
l'Abbé Pierre.
A coup sûr, ils auraient suffi à
ce que vous l'excluiez de votre
cadre républicain, mais où se
cache la République dans votre
cadre républicain?
Où est la République quand une
petite poignée s'accapare tout et
qu'il ne reste rien pour les
autres?
L'impôt est réparti parmi les
citoyens selon leur faculté.
A partir des 0,1% des plus riches,
il devient régressif.
Le taux d'impôt sur le revenu des
milliardaires est proche de 0.
Une telle accumulation ne peut se
faire que sur le dos des autres.
Alors, madame la Première ministre
du prétendu arc républicain, je
vous le demande: où est la
République quand les 500 plus
grandes fortunes s'accaparent près
de la moitié des richesses
produites pendant que un Français
sur trois ne dispose plus que de
200 euros sur son compte bancaire
dès le 10 du mois?
Où est la République quand le plus
fortuné gagne en 24 heures ce
qu'un salarié au SMIC ne
parviendra pas à gagner dans toute
sa vie?
Où est la République sans
légalité?
Où est la République sans la
justice sociale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gabriel
Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Monsieur le député, vous pouvez
tordre les choses dans tous les
sens que vous le souhaitez, tordre
les chiffres, vous n'arriverez pas
à faire croire qu'un pays qui est
le deuxième pays des 38 pays de
l'OCDE en matière de prélèvements
obligatoires est un paradis
fiscal.
Vous n'arriverez pas à faire
croire qu'un pays qui est le
dernier pays de l'Union Européenne
à avoir un impôt national sur la
fortune est un paradis fiscal.
Vous n'arriverez pas à faire
croire qu'un pays où 10% des
contribuables payent 75% de
l'impôt sur le revenu est un
paradis fiscal.
La réalité, c'est que la France
n'est un paradis fiscal pour
personne.
Vous citez nos réformes fiscales,
et notamment le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique.
Si la France est un paradis
fiscal, ça veut dire que
l'Espagne, vos amis de Podemos,
c'est un super paradis fiscal.
Ca veut dire que l'Allemagne, où
les sociaux-démocrates sont au
pouvoir, est un super paradis
fiscal.
On continue à taxer plus que nos
voisins européens.
La France n'est un paradis fiscal
pour personne, mais vous voulez en
faire un enfer fiscal pour tout le
monde.
On a vu les amendements que vous
avez déposés.
Vous voulez taxer les ouvriers qui
font des heures supplémentaires.
Vous voulez taxer les patrons de
PME qui recrutent des salariés au
SMIC.
Vous avez même proposé de taxer
les successions dès le premier
euro alors même que 80% des
successions sont exonérées des
droits de succession dans notre
pays.
C'est la vraie différence entre
vous et nous.
Vous voulez taxer tout ce qui
bouge, même si ça bouge ailleurs,
ça ne vous pose pas de problème.
On souhaite que la richesse soit
faite en France et qu'elle
bénéficie à tous les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Béatrice
Roullaud pour le groupe
Rassemblement National.
- Béatrice Roullaud: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la
Souveraineté alimentaire.
C'est bientôt la fin des travaux
parlementaires et, depuis le 1er
juillet, le départ en vacances
pour beaucoup de Français.
Cette période heureuse se heurte
pourtant au mur bien triste de la
réalité des abandons allant de
pair avec les départs en vacances.
Chaque été, c'est près de 60.000
animaux délaissés pour cause de
congés.
Chaque année, c'est plus de
100.000 animaux domestiques
abandonnés par ceux qui les ont
voulus, soit près de 12 par heure.
Cette année 2023 sera pire encore
car les foyers comme les refuges
subissent de plein fouet la hausse
vertigineuse de l'inflation et de
l'énergie.
La France détient le record
européen des abandons, les refuges
débordent, il faut agir.
Ils sont essentiellement privés
car il n'existe aucun refuge
public dans bien des départements,
et notamment le mien, en
Seine-et-Marne.
La fondation 30 millions d'amis
indique que ses structures sont
saturées et qu'elles subissent une
hausse drastique des dépenses.
L'électricité va encore augmenter.
On ne parle même pas du prix des
croquettes, qui a fait un bond
inimaginable.
La fondation en appelle à la
générosité des Français, qui ont
déjà bien du mal à boucler les
fins de mois.
Certains ont dû se séparer de
leurs compagnons à quatre pattes.
Les donateurs ne peuvent plus
supporter seuls la charge des
refuges.
Alors, malgré les efforts déjà
faits sous les gouvernements
Macron pour prévenir les abandons,
comme l'interdiction des ventes en
animalerie, êtes-vous prêt à créer
des refuges publics ou à
subventionner davantage les
associations?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: la parole est
à monsieur Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci.
Vous avez raison de poser cette
question, en particulier dans
cette période estivale.
C'est la période qui rencontre le
plus d'abandons d'animaux de
compagnie.
C'est la volonté du gouvernement,
vous l'avez souligné avec
honnêteté, que de lutter contre
l'abandon.
Un animal n'est pas un objet.
Un animal n'est pas un jouet.
Ce travail que nous avons fait au
travers d'une loi de 2021 a permis
de renforcer les sanctions en
termes d'amendes et de peines de
prison.
Les sanctions sont aggravées en
cas de mort de l'animal.
Nous avons également oeuvré sur la
sensibilisation et l'information
de ceux qui souhaitent acquérir ou
adopter un animal.
C'est ce que nous faisons avec des
campagnes estivales.
Ca permet à tout le monde de se
retrouver devant ses
responsabilités.
Par l'acte d'acquisition, on doit
être sensibilisé à l'abandon.
Pour l'essentiel des associations,
comme vous le savez, le
gouvernement a accompagné
puissamment la modernisation des
refuges.
Comme vous le dites, les besoins
sont plus importants.
J'ai rencontré un certain nombre
d'associations et de services.
Nous continuons à regarder comment
nous pouvons continuer à les
accompagner en investissement et
concernant les charges de
fonctionnement, qui sont
importantes.
On est à la fois sur des
dispositions législatives...
On a déjà accompagné les refuges
et on est en train de regarder sur
d'autres besoins d'investissement
ce qui peut être couvert.
Il faut d'abord lutter contre
l'abandon.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame la
députée?
- Béatrice Roullaud: Je vous
remercie.
Je crois entendre en filigrane que
vous allez procéder à des
augmentations de subventions.
Je prépare une proposition de loi
sur le sujet.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Stella
Dupont pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Stella Dupont: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Jean-Christophe Combe.
Monsieur le ministre, en France,
le taux de non-recours à certaines
prestations sociales dépasse les
30%.
Nous savons que ce non-recours
accroît la précarité et
l'isolement des personnes
concernées, mais les empêche aussi
d'en sortir.
Lutter contre le non-recours est
un axe stratégique de la lutte
contre la pauvreté.
Ainsi, l'amendement de ma collègue
instaure une expérimentation de
territoires zéro non-recours aux
droits pendant trois ans.
Depuis, un appel à projets a été
lancé et 39 territoires ont été
sélectionnés début juillet pour
participer à cette
expérimentation.
Je me réjouis qu'un territoire
dans mon département ait été
retenu.
Cela illustre l'engagement vers un
meilleur accès aux droits.
Nous voulons développer
l'information sur les droits,
étendre la démarche d'aller vers
et mobiliser les acteurs.
L'enjeu sera d'identifier et
d'accompagner les personnes pour
qu'elles bénéficient de 100% de
leurs droits: RSA, primes
de salarié, chèques énergie...
On aura l'occasion d'évoquer les
moyens dont nous disposons.
Pouvez-vous nous préciser quel
sera le soutien de l'Etat durant
ces trois prochaines années?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Merci.
Madame la députée, merci pour
votre question, qui me permet de
revenir sur un dispositif précieux
qui a été prévu dans le cadre de
la loi 3DS.
Vous aviez été nombreux à y
contribuer.
Je salue notamment votre collègue.
Avec l'expérimentation territoires
zéro non-recours, nous sommes en
plein coeur de la démarche en
faveur de l'accès aux droits que
porte cette majorité depuis
maintenant plusieurs années.
Les maisons France service ont
permis de proposer une offre
élargie de services au public au
plus près des besoins des
personnes sur tout le territoire
ou encore la réforme en cours de
la solidarité à la source.
Le 6 juillet, j'ai eu le plaisir
de présenter une liste non pas de
10, mais de 39 candidatures
retenues sur 67 dossiers soumis.
Ces chiffres témoignent de l'envie
d'avoir un grand nombre d'acteurs
locaux, prêts à se mobiliser
auprès du gouvernement pour
l'accès à chacun aux justes
droits.
Les territoires seront soutenus
par l'Etat à hauteur de 80% des
montants engagés pendant trois
ans.
Ils bénéficieront par ailleurs
d'un dispositif qui permettra aux
acteurs engagés de partager leurs
bonnes pratiques et de comparer
leurs résultats.
Avec l'ensemble des acteurs
participant au comité de
coordination pour l'accès aux
droits, nous serons attentifs aux
effets de ces démarches qui seront
bien sûr évaluées par un comité
dédié.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La séance des questions au
gouvernement est terminée.
La séance est suspendue pour 15
minutes.